this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
some said that tending bar within walks
a pretty old thing named Felicia now a
lot of people know Felicia is sort of a
traditional fighter she's half cat half
woman very popular character she comes
in sits down starts tapping her claws at
the bar and she says bartender
as a young Jesus he's seen the trailer
for this new Dark Knight Rises now
what's great doesn't it she says just
see the actress that got to play
Catwoman she says don't you think it's
funny how they got someone who's
entirely human to play a Catwoman and
yet I'm standing here half cat half
woman and I know they even got an
invitation
I guess that is strange I suppose she's
estranged it's an abomination I can't
believe they never came to meet me to
play the role of Catwoman it's
inexcusable things happen she says no
I'll make them happen I said what do you
mean no she says this is the rule often
born to play literally I've been born
with catkin I have to play a part named
Catwoman I said all right but the movies
already shown is practically edited what
are you gonna do you know she said I was
thinking the exact same thing so I went
on over and I visited my good friend
Sean Young No god I thought and I also
said you mean the same woman who dressed
up like Catwoman for Tim Burton in order
to try and get the part
she said yeah that's the one and I'll
say didn't work for her she says no but
that's because she was a bad actress I
was afraid to inquire this but then I
have to ask what this Shawn young tell
you to do when she I said take no
prisoners is what Sean Young said I mean
look at her she stood by could have been
Catwoman but instead she owes that chick
nobody remembers from do also do she
said yeah that movie nobody remembers
and I said Sean Young is right I'm gonna
go in I'm gonna take no prisoners and
I'm gonna do what's right what to do she
said I went in there I stormed into Tim
Burton and I said I deserve the pot not
said the Tim Burton isn't directing this
movie she said I know that's my first
mistake offense dog did to Christopher
Nolan's placement and demanded him that
I get the pot now so well that's strange
I don't think Christopher Nolan would
keep his address known and she said that
was my second mistake apparently there's
another Christopher Nolan who's a Baldy
building black man who wanted to see me
dead and clearly he listed his address
because he has nothing to fear
and I'll say well what happened to you
she said let me put it this way I don't
need to be neutered anymore answer okay
well you made these two major mistakes
what did you finally end up doing and
she says well finally I found the
location of the real Christopher Nolan
or kidnapped it from this place and I
put him in a secret location no one will
ever find it so when she said on the
corner of 22nd at first no one will ever
find it
unfortunately she said the cops heard
about what I was doing and they tried
tracing me down you know guns a-blazing
and all that stuff but luckily she said
I have a few nitro bombs then I tossed
their way and well let's just say they
won't be messing with me anymore
no said I think they've been messing
with you and mother after that but she
said yeah the police will but not those
cops I mean they are dead dc's no more
do you think this was really one that
the play Catwoman she says oh yeah
acha be as famous as Eartha Kitt she
said you could be his thing this is the
Unabomber tomato tomahto
she says back to me and she says I don't
want to talk anymore about it and I said
well could you at least tell me what
happened after that she said oh it's
still going on yeah the cops have
surrounded the pixel palates they're
going to break in at any moment they're
just waited to make their move realize
the place did so it looks like the cast
of police academy and proceeded to Oscar
um you think you could get out of it she
says absolutely it's okay if I have this
on the house or else I'll slit your
throat and I said that's fine that she
said okay
she ran out all the cops started firing
on her a bloody mess
finally they cuff turned they sent her
off to prison I was nice enough to tell
them the location of mr. Nolan
apparently she was subjecting him to all
sorts of horrible torture she chained
him to a chair forcing him to watch all
the Schumacher batman movies oh my god
that's cruelty and then this Schumacher
Co ostrich things as a bartender is very
strange things at the pizza palace so
I'll see a little strange things as a
bartender at the pixel palace
you